what two months ago was looking like
certain defeat for democrats in the fall
and the impossibility of a joe biden
re-election amidst a strong trump
with a strong desantis either
poised to win the 2024 presidential
election has shifted so dramatically in
such a short period of time where it is
trump now under criminal investigation
after an fbi search warrant executed at
his house including possible charges
violating the espionage act and on the
other side
joe biden's presidency
is looking very very good i'm going to
outline for you in a moment each bullet
point to make up this incredible 180 for
the biden administration
but i want to remind everybody before
your oh david you democratic shill
david you're in the tank for the dnc
you've loved biden all along i've been
very cool on biden i expected very
little from biden
and up until weeks ago i was telling you
approval rating in the toilet
uh unlikely re-election it's just
looking terribly very few
accomplishments to speak of
and it has changed dramatically i call
it like it is i'm not a democrat i don't
care about the democratic party so let's
go through these things item by item
uh first real quick i want to tell you
about our sponsor aura i've talked on
the show before about how we have dealt
with hacking and it's a terrible feeling
you have to act quickly the problem can
get worse fast if you don't and i now
protect myself with aura aura monitors
my email addresses passwords bank
accounts credit cards all of that stuff
and sends me alerts if anything has been
compromised it's identity theft
protection and fraud monitoring all
wrapped together aura continuously
monitors the dark web looking for your
private info you get an alert as soon as
something is discovered aura also does
things like alert you if there are
suspicious credit inquiries if someone
opens or tries to open an account in
your name i've gotten useful alerts from
my aura app and i was able to act on
them quickly if you don't have a tool
like aura i highly recommend it and when
you go to aura.com pacman you will get
aura free for 14 days which you can use
to do things like see if your passwords
have been leaked the link is down below
alright so
look at the list of accomplishments that
joe biden suddenly has to his name and
if you believe it's the economy stupid
as james carville said in the 1990s then
you have to see
a very bright outlook for democrats in
november and even potentially for joe
biden in 2024 if he decides to run again
so on the one hand
we've got the economy
inflation is going down last report
shows inflation lower uh in july than it
was in june that's a good thing for joe
biden it's a good thing for the economy
gas prices have now declined for what is
the number of consecutive days it's
basically since mid-june
62 63 consecutive days of gas price
declines i never thought that biden had
anything to do with gas prices going up
i don't believe he has anything to do
with them going down but these metrics
get attached to whoever is president for
all the people that blamed biden for
high gas prices you've got to give them
the credit for them going down as silly
as i think all of this is so inflation
down gas price is down july jobs report
we were expecting 250 000 new jobs we
got over 500 000. the number of new jobs
in july was more than double the
expected number
the inflation reduction act
is going forward the pact act much
lobbied for by former daily show host
jon stewart is done
the killing of the terrorist leader
ayman al-zawahiri i'm a progressive i
have real concerns about the lack of due
process when these killings are done i'm
right there with every single one of you
but by the standards of what is
considered an accomplishment for a
president
yet another accomplishment
wages up in july half of a percent so
you've got tons of jobs
stock markets stable and up with a
fantastic july and a very nice early
august so far
people are making more and things are
costing less and look at the alternative
it's trump
posting on truth social
about how it was very wrong
for the documents that he had which he
shouldn't have had to be taken from
mar-a-lago
a dramatically different situation from
what we had two months ago
joe biden's approval is increasingly
reflecting it um at last check joe
biden's approval after bottoming out at
37 percent has already gotten back up to
about 41
a modest change but a very very clear
inflection point that started uh in the
second half of july
democrats could actually do okay
november
joe biden could plausibly be re-elected
in 24 if he chooses to run which i still
am very unsure of
let me know what you think things not
looking very good for trump
looking pretty good for joe biden